how do you think about these crazy
evaluations
uh and having not lived through the wars
clone wars or the empire yeah
those are star wars references it was
like harry potter but before that
hey cool i'll look it up after this yeah
um no yeah i it's kind of a loaded
question there's a lot to unpack i think
ultimately like i
don't expect any multiple expansion on
any investment that i make probably
expect some
multiple contraction and that could be
on
revenue users hype whatever multiple
you're paying
so i think anytime i make an investment
the value has come from actual execution
and just like growing the like making a
fundamentally like sound business that
is eventually a publicly traded company
and i think if you if you invest in a
seed round and it goes public in 10
years
you might get a 20x you might get 100x
but you'll make money
so i don't get too worked up about
the exact nuances of it especially for
this fund like if i was
if like i think any check that's like
100 000
150 can return a 10 million dollar fund
you're not a leading round so the way i
kind of approach it right now is you
really just find trying to find the best
founders and products and companies and
teams and just back them and you're kind
of building a track record in the future
you have to have to be a little bit more
sensitive about what the ownership looks
like and
you know you look what the valuations
are i do i have backed out around which
like i just think this valuation is kind
of crazy don't have a lot of conviction
in it etc so you kind of so that is kind
of interesting you're taking the
valuation and your conviction and you're
taking those two vectors and saying hey
i'm high conviction and then this is how
delighted i am with the evaluation if
you put it on an xy obviously if you
think it's a reasonable evaluation
reasonable unreasonable you can kind of
plot on an xy chart if it's a reasonable
evaluation and you have high conviction
you're pulling the trigger
you know reasonable value even like
unreasonable valuation high conviction
you might actually pull the trigger
right yeah you're going to give them
credit for
their series b essentially at the seed
round
that i i really don't think that's
happened
so
i mean clubhouse was 100 million dollars
and that yeah that was your series b
prize previously and i thought it was
kind of
crazy i didn't have enough conviction in
clubhouse i didn't even really try to
invest i probably couldn't have i tried
a couple of times but mark andreessen
was in it and as i previously oh yeah
mentioned we have a little bit of a
uh yeah
yeah yeah work on that relationship he's
the man no i mean i just think you
that's one of the things about being
early is you answer to nobody if you're
willing to do the work i mean think
about how painful our job is being the
earliest investors you we have to have
conviction
when the product maybe hasn't even
touched consumers yet
or there's 10 customers right i mean how
do you make decisions
do you actually talk to customers at
this point do you look at data uh or
just look at the product and get to know
the founder and that's enough for you
for me oh yeah it's a little it's a mix
of everything
i think data is always helpful you want
to be able to benchmark it and you but
the thing is
almost i think like the sweet spot is
decent data like there's some promise
there's a lot that needs to that could
be better and you can just tell based on
playing with the product and talking to
the founder like oh
the data is going to look way better in
the future they're going to make the
metrics look better and the valuation is
very fair because of that like it all
reflects it and you have the conviction
that oh they'll be they'll easily be
able to hire some
some engineers to just go a little bit
faster and like they just they just need
the money and they'll
execute on all these things that need to
happen to kind of close all this and
pick all this low-hanging fruit that
they still use that's almost like the
sweet spot that i try to look for is
like there's some proof point there's
some traction there's still some
questions and that's typically when it's
like seed
when it's like a series most things
haven't been fit most things haven't
been figured out but something promising
has emerged as if i'm reflecting back to
you what you're saying
yeah it depends on stage like i've done
some precede it's like pre-launch the
founders 20 years old
has never started a company before
but you can just tell based on the
conversation like you you pull out all
these things she's done throughout her
life and you're like
okay i should probably make the bet now
because i will regret not doing it
because it just feels like she's
probably going to keep
doing all these impressive things and it
will now be through a company instead of
you know
running tuition or running uh tutoring
classes in high school and like getting
into a good college from like a bad
background and like all the stuff that
she's done so you kind of try to find
those there's like the famous thing
saying it's like you invest in in lines
not dots so you kind of if there's no
lines you try to like go backwards and
like produce the lines that happened
before you met the founder and like or
before they even have any actual data or
progress on their company
and then when it's like series b c
typically for me it's more of
uh like do i feel like my spreadsheet is
going to be way like that the market
size in my spreadsheet could be 10 or
100 times bigger than how everyone else
is thinking about it like all this
boring
you know this lame consumer app actually
has like you know 100 times more people
could potentially use this based on some
new features they're adding down the the
pipeline and
20 times subscription revenue is
actually a fair valuation
because of all these things that they'll
do
and again it's super contextual very
nuanced it's not like a
one sentence kind of answer but you kind
of try to think about all these things
and i kind of try to back into like do i
think this founder is going to build a
publicly created company that's
ultimately what i try to find and you
know try to look for like comps like oh
there's this big dumb
legacy 100 old company that does
50 billion in revenue and like their
executives print their emails to read
them or like they still use faxes so
it's an interesting company to compete
against if you're a tech startup so yeah
you just try to find like all these
different little things to kind of piece
together and like honestly i don't go
out and try to invest in like
this is a slam dunk home run super
obvious to everyone
that's generally not what i'm investing
in unless i have some kind of unique
edge in and like the founder really
likes me the things that are consensus
uh generally exist in the world already
or are so obvious they've probably been
tried already and people have failed
it's the non-consensus bets you know
airbnb famously pitched 37 venture firms
before they got a yes um at the open
angel forum when travis presented uber
three of us invested and 19 didn't uh
marx just wrote a famous blog post about
not investing wow and so you know and i
introduced
tesla to dozens of venture capitalists
and you know just email friends like hey
you know you should take a look at this
they're like car company are you crazy
did you
i didn't i wasn't an angel investor at
the time uh i was always people always
ask me that and it was like i wasn't an
angel investor but elon was raising
money and i just emailed a bunch of
friends who and that's actually how i
wound up becoming a scout of sequoia was
i had emailed them and said hey you know
i know you know i know you know elon
really well he's making progress on this
i just drove in the prototype i ordered
one like this isn't going to be
incredible and then i emailed twitter
and i was like
michael moritz and roloff you just have
to do this deal does it matter that fred
wilson is over bidding like and i had
been talking to the the twitter folks
and they were asking me hey what do you
think of you you've got backing from
sequoia that's all being my
autobiography at some point but and fred
wilson was doing the deal and
evan was like hey what do you think of
fred because i know you're friends with
fred and fred's wifey's dwarf and i was
like fred's the nuts he's amazing like
east coast vc but you know and back then
east coast vc was kind of a negative
signal and he's like and what do you
think of sequoia and i was like well you
know honestly like sequoia you can't go
you know sequoia versus fred wilson like
if you were in new york i'd say go fred
wilson if you're in the west coast maybe
it's sequoia like you this is like
picking between like two of the best
options
um and sequoia didn't close the deal and
fred did so i didn't do tesla and then i
told them to do my friend's poker app
uh which eventually became zynga but it
was online
so all three of those they passed on and
then they were like can we just give you
money and you invested
and i did uber thumbtack and data stacks
of my first six or seven investments so
three unicorns in the first seven
uh and that's basically the serendipity
of how my career started was i i had
been forwarding so many founders and
that really is like your story as well
have apple's new privacy updates
impacted your attribution from paid ads
i bet it has well good news the folks at
disruptive advertising can help you
disruptive advertising manages over 250
million dollars a year in advertising
spend and they are trusted by hundreds
of brands like adobe and scott's miracle
gross so if your google and facebook ads
are not scaling like they used to you
should do a consultation with disruptive
they will look to help you scale your
spend profitably how by diversifying
your ad strategy on less popular
platforms will track every single dollar
that you spend or earn and their
marketing consultants focus on
end-to-end tracking across your crm
marketing automations and e-commerce
platform they care less about return on
spend what they really focus on is
contribution margin profitability and
closed deals so here is your call to
action get a thousand dollars off your
first month of service at
disruptiveadvertising.com
twist disruptive advertising dot com
slash twist for 1 000
off